[Music]
welcome back
in this video we want to share the
approach to an api product mindset
and give you examples on how to design
your first api product
let's get started i often get this
question from my customers at the start
of an engagement
what is an api the formal definition of
api is defined as
application programming interface it is
a way for systems to communicate with
each other
it leverages and reuses data functions
and applications
and combines them into new business
opportunities
and furthermore it connects consumers of
data
systems and applications with providers
of the same
now that you have the formal definition
you are probably asking yourself
how does this affect my business
in the next few slides we will discuss a
recommended approach to designing your
apis
making it easier for the developer to
discover and begin using your apis
in order to implement their application
with speed
so now you may ask what is an api
product
and why is it important to my business
approaching an api with the consumer
experience in mind
is the cornerstone of an api product we
call this
an api first approach or outside in
thinking
let me give you an example for those of
you who are mba fans
when you think of steph curry's
basketball shoes you might envision a
cool blue and white shoe
that enables you to jump higher and
farther than anyone else
on the court you might envision yourself
shooting three-point baskets from
mid-court
now the shoe doesn't really do that but
it creates the vision of someone doing
awesome things when they wear that shoe
you want to build
the same vision or need with an api
product
with a focus on the consumer experience
the api product can encompass a similar
vision and experience for an api
let's dig into how this is done to
understand the need for an api product
you must first understand the user
let's start with asking four key
questions centered around
the user of your api who is the user
what are the user's needs why do they
need it when
do they need it the answer to the first
question is simple
the user of your api is an application
developer who will create
applications using your api the
application developer is also known as
the api consumer
let me give you an example a lottery
company in the uk
wanted to make purchasing a lottery
ticket easy for their players
their goal was to give everyone the
ability to make a purchase
anytime anywhere however there were some
regulations that needed to be met before
the player could purchase the ticket
first the purchase of a lottery ticket
must be made from within the uk
this requires that the application be
able to geo-locate the player
luckily most telcos have a location api
available for use
next the lottery requires the purchaser
to be at least
16 years of age therefore the
application must be able to identify the
player
and look up the player's profile to
determine if the minimum age
qualifications are met
this can be done through an identity api
once the minimum qualifications have
been met
and the player is ready to purchase the
application must provide the ability to
pay the billing api
allows the application to accept payment
and the player to complete the purchase
of a lottery ticket
the api product is formed as a
collection of apis that provides the
user with the experience of purchasing a
lottery ticket
and ensuring that the minimum
qualifications are met
purchase must be made within the uk
purchaser must be at least 16 years of
age
payment can be completed as part of that
transaction
furthermore including reusable assets
such as an enterprise security policy
and a traffic management policy will
ensure adherence to corporate
requirements
enabling faster time to market because
the lottery api product packages
all of the necessary items applications
can be quickly created to allow
purchasing of lottery tickets over a
wide variety of experience
that is convenient for the player like
online
mobile app and kiosk purchases another
example of the api product mindset
is with one of our customers who is the
leader in ticket sales and distribution
the company uses apis to enable
customers to discover events
such as concerts or sporting events and
provides the ability to purchase tickets
on the spot
this capability is provided through apis
made available to partners who include
the features within their applications
perhaps you are planning a weekend
getaway and want to reserve a hotel room
in the process of reserving a room on
the hotel website you might see a link
to explore events within the local area
the link allows you to discover events
in the area and enables you to buy
tickets
a one-stop shop to complete your weekend
getaway agenda
to enable this experience api products
make it easy for partners to create the
user experience
let's take a closer look at this partner
api product
the company's partner api product
addresses two key challenges
how to enable both internal developers
and partner developers
and how to ensure the appropriate level
of security to stop
bots from circumventing limits placed on
ticket purchases
since security was a must-have that
policy was
automatically included in the api
product
in addition consumers wanted to find
events using various search criteria
search by artists such as beyonce search
by venue like the at t stadium
and search by dates for the event the
discovery api had all of the necessary
calls to obtain the event data
finally in order to reserve and purchase
the tickets
you need a commerce api to complete the
transaction
this could all be bundled in a simple to
use api product
over the course of its use the company
found that the needs of the partner
developer
were the same as the needs of the
internal developer
so one api product could meet the needs
of both types of api consumers
now that you have an understanding of
the api product mindset
how do you go about building an api
product
let's dig into this key factors in
building an api product are
design your api product with an outside
in mindset
this requires understanding your
customer and the use case
in the case of the national lottery
focused on the player
you might take on the persona as a
player consumer i want to purchase a
lottery ticket while i'm on the go
for wealth management as an individual
investor
i want to view my account holdings or as
a financial advisor
i want to view my clients account
holdings
taking a look at the consumer's view
informs how to design your api product
from the most common use
cases next take a look at the needs of
your application developers who will
create the experience for your customers
they need a way to get started quickly
with your api product
that's why documentation is so important
but documentation alone is not enough
make it easy for your developers to
discover your apis
say through an apigee developer portal
the documentation makes the apis
accessible
and finally review the analytics to
determine what works well
and what needs improvement then continue
to iterate to improve your api products
gone are the field of dreams there's so
much information bombarding you through
the world wide web
email campaigns social media and even
robocalls to disturb you that everyone
is on information overload
in order to get the attention that your
api product deserves
you have to market and evangelize your
product directly to your target audience
focus on your developer needs give them
what they want as far as ease of use
onboarding and adoption and make it fast
and easy to consume
api product mindset means understanding
the needs of others in the digital value
chain
both upstream and downstream the
application developer is the consumer of
your api product
documentation describing the product is
the key
to its success likewise
for developers to get started quickly
with an api product
you must provide foundational
information to get started
such as what data does the api product
provide how to access it
and what is the format of the data to
recap
the api product mindset consists of
three key focus areas
focus on the user experience think
outside in and get a good understanding
of the user's needs in order to create a
positive experience
make it easy to consume with
documentation and sample code
time to market is key every enterprise
company is jumping on board to enable
digital assets
the first to market will have a leg up
on their competitors iterate
don't try to boil the ocean but design
for extensibility
design for the basic value proposition
get feedback
and continue to iterate to improve the
product thanks for your time and be sure
to watch the next video to learn about
customer journeys